bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 12 février
merci de nous rejoindre dans filecho
votre émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale
aujourd'hui nous vous proposons un
numéro un peu spécial autour du thème de
l'emploi vous le savez nous en avons
parlé dans les émissions précédentes
c'est la 19e semaine de l'emploi qui se
déroule en ce moment et jusqu'au samedi
14 février à 50 ans en Eveline à cette
occasion nous vous proposons deux
dossiers l'un sur le recrutement et
l'autre sur les jeunes et l'entreprise
nous en discuterons ensuite avec nos
trois invités bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoiroir alors nous sommes avec
jeunevev alin vous êtes directrice en
ressources ressources humaines et coach
certifié Christophe Eva vous êtes
directeur du cabinet àal tbin power
recrutement et ingénierie RH et vous
êtes également vice-président de
convergence Eveline fait et Henry Vatin
vous êtes délégué de l'association
Jeunesse et entreprise élu de la Chambre
de Commerce et d'Industrie et ex-decteur
d'établissement Thalès et bien vous
serez là pour répondre avec nous à
toutes nos questions sur justement ces
deux dossiers avant cela je vous propose
de passer au dossier
recrutement le recrutement est une
problématique au cœur de l'emploi les
pratiques ont changé pour les salariés
comme pour les entreprises il est
parfois un petit peu difficile de s'y
retrouver à l'occasion de la 19e semaine
de l'emploi nous sommes allés au forum
du recrutement à 5ant Eveline ainsi qu'à
des ateliers dédiés à ces questions pour
tenter d'y voir un peu plus clair
regardez ce dossier préparé avec Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude romain rpini pour le
montage 10h du matin et déjà la foule se
presse au théâtre de 5 an en Yveline
l'objet de ce rassemblement c'est le
forum du recrutement muni de leur CV ces
ivelinois viennent rencontrer les 13
entreprises présentes sur les stands
c'est quelque chose qui est attractif
donc ça va permettre à certaines
personnes qui ne trouvent pas un emploi
de trouver un emploi donc là on voit
directement l'employilleur dans le
contact direct avec la personne donc
c'est plus concret que d'envoyer un CV
par Internet parce qu'il y a aucune
relation c'est très bien pour les
chercheurs passant les CV qu'on envoie
dans les sociétés ça marche pas souvent
rencontrer l'employeur en face à face
être plus qu'un CV parmi d'autres un
besoin pour les 600 personnes présentes
durant la matinée mais pas seulement les
entreprises ciblent également ces grands
rendez-vous souvent spécialisés ici une
centaine de postes dans les métiers du
transport de la logistique du commerce
ou de la restauration sont proposés les
ressources humaines ont ainsi
l'assurance de pouvoir recruter
localement on les rencontre en direct
donc on s'arrête pas sur effectivement
un profil quand on reçoit le CV on va
regarder le diplôme on va regarder les
expériences alors que là on rencontre la
personne en direct donc effectivement on
peut voir si le feeling passe et puis
par la suite les rencontrer une deuxième
fois pour pouvoir vraiment la statuer
sur le CV pour certains c'est un
recrutement plus efficace et plus rapide
dans ce stand de groupement d'employeurs
une trentaine de postes est proposé ici
l'offre est moins traditionnelle et
nécessite quelques explications on a des
postes oui concrets on peut proposer des
postes en extra en CDD ou en
CDI sachant que le cœur de métier du du
groupement d'employeur c'est le temps
partagé à savoir que les salariés sont
en contrat CDI avec réseau et travaille
dans plusieurs établissements différents
pour ce forum organisation a contacté
250 entreprises et moins de 10 % ont
répondu à l'appel en général une société
utilise en moyenne 4 canaux différents
pour trouver des candidats tels que des
agences d'emploi ou des cabinets de
recrutement parmi eux Internet est très
plébisité selon une étude publiée en
2014 par la PEC 56 à 60 % des
entreprises françaises utilisent les
réseaux sociaux pour recruter via Deo et
Linkedin des réseaux sociaux
professionnels représentent
respectivement plus de 9 et 8 millions
d'utilisateurs en France
ces nouvelles tendances sont autant de
paramètres à gérer pour les ressources
humaines à l'occasion de la Semaine de
l'emploi la maison de l'entreprise a
organisé avec plateforme RH des ateliers
pour répondre à ces problématiques ce
sont quand même des petites entreprises
des petites structures essentiellement
des entreprises de moins de50 de 50
salariés leur cœur de métier c'est de
ramener du business c'est de faire vivre
leur structure de payer bien évidemment
leur salariés à la fin du mois et toutes
les problématiques liées ben au
recrutement et à toutes ces nouvelles
formes de recrutement c'est pas des
c'est pas des domaines dans laquel ils
sont experts en France 31 % des
entreprises ont eu recours à un
prestataire externe lors de leur dernier
recrutement de cadre on donne ce travail
là au RH en fait les RH ont de plus en
plus de missions à remplir et donc et
ben ils ont de moins en moins de temps
finalement donc c'est vrai qu'ils
peuvent avoir besoin de sociétés de
conseil pour les accompagner sur ces
thématique au-delà des façons de
recruter les changements existent aussi
sur les modes d'emploi choisis c'est
aussi l'objet de ces des réunions
d'information ce chef d'entreprise de
TPE emploie 7 personnes et recherche
plus de flexibilité le travail
partagé la possibilité du partage
salarial sont des solutions qu'on peut
envisager avec la crise chaque
recrutement est considéré comme un
investissement le niveau d'exigence est
alors plus élevé une difficulté de plus
pour parer au chômage en novembre 2014
dans les ivelines Pôle Emploi recensait
96000 demandeurs d'emploi en catégorie A
B C un nombre qui a augmenté de 6,1 %
depu depuis
2013 alors première question dans notre
entretien je vousla POS à vous à
jeunevalin est-ce qu'il faut privilégier
les forums les réseaux sociaux quelle
est un peu la meilleure solution quand
en charge du travail je pense qu'il faut
tout tout privilégier ne pas avoir
forcément ne pas être forcément que sur
les réseaux sociaux mais tout même de la
cooptation ce que nous on appelle la
cooptation c'est-à-dire en fait le
voisin
les collègues de sport et cetera parler
en fait de sa recherche à un maximum de
personnes et faire tous les canaux
possibles pour se faire remarquer
christop vous êtes d'accord avec ça
alors je je suis d'accord effectivement
sur le fait qu'un candidat doit
positionner effectivement sa candidature
sur tous les dispositifs possibles en
sachant quand même qu'aujourd'hui on a
nous en en feedback par rapport à nos
activités de cabinet de recrutement j'ai
amené deux trois chiffres d'ailleurs
iussi de notre base de données de
candidat on a vu en fait une évolution
importante des gens qu'on a recruté
notamment à travers les réseaux sociaux
donc viaadoo linkid par exemple en en en
92 on avait que 45 % des gens qu'on a
recruté au sein du cabinet qui venaient
des réseaux sociaux en 2013 on en a eu
67 % et en 2014 on est à 87 % ça veut
dire que 87 % des candidats qu'on a
recruté dans le cadre de notre cabinet
pour nos clients provenait des réseaux
sociaux alors je pense que ça s'explique
par le fait qu'aujourd'hui sur le marché
du travail où on est les gens ont besoin
de prendre un petit peu de recul et
effectivement les réseaux sociaux
permettent d'avoir une certaine vitrine
de filtrer aussi avec une certaine
distance par rapport au recruteurs mais
en même temps ça donne une une image sur
ce qu'on appelle de la IR recommandation
c'estàd un process un peu nouveau ce qui
par permet aussi au recruteurs de
vérifier un peu le fil de l'évolution de
carrière des personnes les passions ce
qui essaie de mettre en avant les gens
en terme de compét il faut absolument
avoir un profil sur les réseaux sociaux
comm pense aujourd'hui c'est
incontournable pour beaucoup de raisons
parce qu'effectivement il y a l'approche
directe faite par les cabinets de
recrutement ou les chasseurs de tête
mais il y a aussi le fait d'avoir un un
média à disposition qui permet ensuite
de faire fonctionner le réseau qui peut
toucher les employés ailleurs des
collègues de retrouver aussi à travers
le réseau des contacts anciens d'école
ou de de sociétés dans lequel on est
passé qui me permettent en fait de créer
un réseau virtuel qui vous permet
d'échanger dans le cas oùê effectivement
vous êtes en recherche de d'emplois ou
de nouvell opportunités hen vin vous
étiez ancien directeur chez taless
est-ce que les démarches sont différent
selon la taille de l'entreprise ou dans
une grande entreprise que ça changea un
petit peu pas nécessairement
c'est c'est plus des des habitudes de
l'histoire je crois que tout le monde
s'oriente vers l'ircrutement he c'est
c'est certainement un des plus de de la
période mais les gens y vont plus ou
moins enfin les entreprises il vont plus
ou moins vite je crois que cette cet
aspect là pour le jeune capitaliser sur
l'ecrutement c'est c'est quand même la
bonne méthode et en fait ça va le lui
faciliter la tâche dans dans le fait
d'être acteur de son recr ement parce
que c'est c'est
pas il faut essayer de comprendre il
faut que le jeune comprenne ce qu'il a
envie de faire il faut que le jeune
comprenne ce que ce que sont les
entreprises avant de se de se présenter
ou de ou de postuler et
le internet permet sur les sites des
entreprises de de de bien comprendre
l'image qu'elle donne d'elle et et de
voir quels sont les postes qui sont
ouverts donc pour les jeunes voilà
Internet les réseaux sociaux c'est quand
même plus facile d'accès pour les
personnes je pense voilà les plus de 45
ans c'est quand même un plus difficile
jeanaling je pense que c'est la même
chose que ce soit pour les jeunes ou
pour les seniors de toute façon
effectivement il faut que un maximum de
personnes soient sur les réseaux sociaux
mais pas uniquement je disais tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait effectivement
faire jouer aussi son propre réseau ses
amis son groupe de sport et cetera parce
que il y a des tas d'annonces qui ne
paraissent pas et qui se font par le
biais justement du contact direct c'est
aussi une autre façon de trouver du
travail et ça de façon beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus simple et plus facile et
les entreprises quand elles recrutent
par ce billet elles ont 80 % de
confiance dans un recrutement dit par
cooptation que d'aller chercher un
candidat sur une cVTech ou sur des
réseaux sociaux parce que cette personne
on ne la connaît pas alors que par le
biais d'une d'une tierce personne on va
déjà avoir plus de connaissance sur
elle notamment exactement pour là on a
parlé donc voilà justement des conseils
un peu au salariés aux gens qui sont en
demandeurs d'emploi pour les entreprises
du coup comme vous êtes vraiment en
relation avec ell quel conseil on
pourrait donner pour réussir son
recrutement est-ce que aussiil faut
aller sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce
qu'il faut je sais pas peut-être CER
plus la recherche parce que les réseaux
sociaux quand même prennent du temps
pour le recrutement mais aussi les
forums de l'emploi ça prend aussi du
temps donc quelle est un petit peu je
sais pas la solution optimale j'ai envie
de dire ça dépend du profil que l'on
recherche si ce sont de jeunes étudiants
de jeunes ingénieurs les forums d'emploi
sont très bien euh si ce sont des
personnes un peu plus seniores sur des
postes euh par exemple des directeurs
les cabinets de recrutement sont aussi
une autre façon de recruter j'ai envie
dire ça c'est fonction vraiment du
profil effectivement il y a il y a un
impact différent en fonction de
l'expérience recherchée par nos clients
il y a effectivement l'accès donc à
travers les réseaux sociaux qui permet
effectivement d'accéder à des
candidatures ensuite vous avez des gens
qui ne sont pas forcément sur des
réseaux sociaux qui sont en anonyme euh
bon ça va peut-être vous paraître un peu
décalé par rapport au Web 2.0 mais nous
au sein de notre cabinet il nous arrive
encore de faire des courriers personnels
à certains candidats qu'on a identifié
soit par le biais d'ancien d'école soit
par le réseau où effectivement on arrive
à trouver leur adresse de domicile à qui
on adresse effectivement un beau
courrier avec la définition de poste en
leur demandant de prendre contact avec
nous dans le cadre d'un recrutement
spécifique donc vous voyez dans le ement
il y a pas de secret magique on a
aujourd'hui un certain nombre d'outils
des médias très performants qui sont les
réseaux sociaux mais néanmoins dans le
recrutement il faut aussi savoir se
différencier et aller trouver les bons
candidats où ils sont ils sont pas
forcément toujours en première
visibilité soit sur un job board soit
sur des réseaux sociaux je crois c'est
c'est très vrai hein l'embauche pour une
entreprise c'est une étape importante
c'est la préparation de l'avenir il est
normal qu'elle y investisse et qu'elle y
passe du temps on peut pas réclamer que
tout soit j'allais dire facile et et
gratuit et donc il y a aussi une Analyse
marketing à faire au préalable pour
savoir où sont les candidats qu'il
recherchent et comment on y accède
certains comme dites par le web d'autres
par les lettres les troisèm par les
forums et le voilà donc c'est bien c'est
bien une c'est bien un processus qu'il
faut mener avec sérieux on par des
entreprises maintenant on va parler de
la relation entre les jeunes et
l'entreprise c'est notre second dossier
de cette
émission les jeunes sont parmi les
premiers touchés par le chômage en
décembre 2014 dans les ivil ils étaient
10660 recensés comme demandeurs d'emploi
dans les catégories A B et C à
l'occasion de la Semaine de l'emploi
nous avons découvert des dispositifs mis
en place dans les ivlines pour aider les
jeunes entre familiarisation avec le
monde de l'entreprise et découverte du
monde professionnel le plus plutôt ou
pardon entre ces initiatives il y a donc
beaucoup de choses regardez ce dossier
de la rédaction Xavier Jalin pour le
montage rapprocher les jeunes du monde
professionnel un défi pour le
département un problème de conjoncture
économique mais pas seulement formation
orientation et méconnaissance du monde
du travail sont aussi en cause des
problématiques auxquelles on tente de
répondre le plus tôt possible à morpa au
lycée des se Mar on multiplie les
contact entre les élèves et le monde de
l'entreprise on a un problème si vous
voulez de culture d'entreprise je crois
en particulier chez les élèves qui
sortent des filières générales la
plupart du temps ces élèves ne côtoient
le monde de l'entreprise qu'après
l'obtention du baccalauréat ces élèves
de première et de BTS participent à un
speed meeting en petit groupe ils ont 15
minutes pour échanger avec des
représentants et chefs d'entreprise je
demandé s'il avait beaucoup voyagé enfin
par rapport à ses entreprises qu'il a
fait pour que ça marche ou ce qu'il a
fait pour que ça ça marche mieux on a
des éléments mais rencontrer un
professionnel ça peut toujours nous
aider et voilà avoir peut-être un appui
sur notre projet l'initiative se
développe de plus en plus en France
aujourd'hui à morpa elle est organisée
par l'association Jeunesse entreprendre
et la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
de Versailles Yveline ils ont fait appel
à des interlocuteurs de l'association
d'entreprise Delta Sky et au réseau
coaction 78 ces hommes et femmes sont
des acteurs privilégiés pour répondre
aux questions sur l'organisation la
hiérarchie ou le fonctionnement d'une
entreprise l'idée c'était de savoir un
petit peu quel était le mon parcours
professionnel et puis des informations
d'ordre général sur sur l'entreprise
donc sur Renault et puis comme c'était
BTS NRC donc plus axé on va dire sur la
politique commerciale de l'entreprise
comprendre le monde du travail n'est pas
une mince àaire certains établissements
n'attendent pas l'entrée au lycée pour
plonger leurs élèves dans le grand bain
are initiative à Fontenis lefleurri le
collège d'cartes mise sur la mini
entreprise explication du projet avec
Anna c'est elle la présidente directrice
générale de l'entreprise reminder on a
créé un pensebê pour les courses avec
plusieurs catégories en
fait il y a il y aura 52 feuilles comme
ça une feuille par semaine dans ce
collège 15 élèves de 3e ont été recrutés
parmi les plus motivés pour intégrer
l'entreprise directeur général
commercial comptable et assistante
marketing tous les postes ont été
pourvus ils doivent assurer la
fabrication et la commercialisation de
leurs produits on a des élèves qui ont
créé le logo qui ont pensé à de la
publicité qui ont vraiment un esprit
artistique il y en a qui ont un esprit
plus commercial donc il pense à des
stratégies de vente enfin c'est chaque
élève en fait finalement propose quelque
chose de d'un peu inédit et en lien
toujours avec l'entreprise ça développe
des compétences pluridisciplinaires donc
ça leur apprend à rédiger ça leur
apprend le monde de l'entreprise donc
pour leur futur orientation de 3è ça les
aide aussi la mini entreprise est épolé
par le gérant d'un centre commercial de
bois d'Arc il leur permet de vendre leur
pense bête dans l'enceinte de son
magasin c'est aussi une figure du monde
de l'entreprise qui les conseille et
répond à leurs questions 3 heur par
semaine les élèves s'impliquent dans ce
projet pédagogique et
professionnel moi c'est un plaisir tous
lesfin tous les jeudis d'aller en DP3 il
y a une bonne ambiance puis je trouve le
principe intéressante domination c'est
la 3è année de suite que le collège
réitère le projet de mini entreprise
l'option découverte professionnelle est
facultative elle existe depuis 2005 et
peut s'étaler entre 3 et 6 he par
semaine chacun fait à l'interne ce qu'il
entend dans cette découverte
professionnelle ça peut être des visites
d'entreprise ça peut être des des
conférenciers ça peut-être des visites
de lycée professionnels et chez nous
nous pensions que la mini entreprise
permettrait de créer une bonne dynamique
au niveau de la des classes de 3e la
classe de 3e un moment clé il définit si
l'enfant doit poursuivre dans une
filière générale technologique ou
professionnelle l'apprentissage fait
partie de ces filières dans les Yvelines
près de 10000 jeunes sont dans cette
voie cela représente 15 % des élèves du
département en France 415000 apprentis
ont été recensés en 2014 le gouvernement
vise un objectif de 500000 jeunes pour
2017 pour la Semaine de l'emploi le
pavillon valdec Rousseau aguill en cour
propose un forum de formation au métier
les formations présenté débouchent
rapidement sur le marché du travail de
nombreux élèves yvelinois étaient
présents parfois sans idée très précise
de ce qu'ils souhaitent faire je pense
qu'on a encore le temps au moins un ou 2
ans avant de prendre une décision par
que c'est important des élèves
accompagnés par leurs parents qui se
posent eux aussi beaucoup de questions
sur le choix difficile de l'orientation
nous il faut qu'on se mette un petit peu
à niveau par rapport à quelles sont les
formations qui existent
aujourd'hui nous on a fait notre
formation mais on ignore complètement
tout ce qui est possible et donc il faut
déjà voir dans sa région et dans les
ivelines toutes les formations qui sont
proposées ici les formations sont
courtes professionnelles et porteuses
d'emploi neuf secteurs sont représentés
parmi lesquels la défense le commerce
les transports ou la santé des domaines
dont on parle beaucoup contrairement aux
établissements présents s'ils forment à
ces métiers ils sont moins connus que
les formation classique et manque de
visibilité la plupart des jeunes ne
connaissent pas forcément tous les
métiers dans certains secteurs
d'activité comme le nôtre ils vont
connaître les métiers traditionnels
ciblees tels que le maçon ou le plombier
mais en fait en réalité dans le domaine
du bâtiment il y a une multitude de
métiers qui se croisent ce genre de
salon permet aussi de de valoriser cette
filière qui est souvent qui peut être
connu des jeunes et apprécié mais c'est
un travail aussi avec les parents à
faire qui souvent peuvent avoir une
image négative de cette filière là
pourtant à la sortie de l'apprentissage
entre 75 et 76 % des apprentis yvelinois
ont un emploi et 66 % d'entre eux sont
en CDI une donnée non négligeable le
nombre de jeunes de moins de 25 ans au
chômage en catégorie A B ou C a augmenté
de 2,5 % entre 2013 et 2014 dans les
ivelines alors hen vin vous avez regardé
donc ce dossier vous connaissez bien ces
initiatives elles sont mis en place dès
la 3è est-ce que ce n'est pas un petit
peu tôt non je crois qu'il faut
accompagner les élèves progressivement
dans la compréhension de l'entreprise et
le premier choix que les élèves vont
avoir à faire c'est bien au niveau de la
troisème est-ce que justement il y d'ut
donc il leur faut excusez-moi il faut
commencer déjà à les sensibiliser bien
sûr il faut que ce soit adapté à l'âge
c'est c'est clair et est-ce que c'est
justement un peu au monde de
l'entreprise ou à l'école de faire un
petit peu des efforts dans ce sens là je
je dirais au deux au monde de
l'entreprise aussi de pouvoir proposer à
des jeunes des stages qui leur
permettent de découvrir le vrai monde de
l'entreprise ça sous-entend qu'il a des
personnes en entreprise qui puissent
justement faire en sorte de les
accueillir de prendre du temps pour bien
accompagner ces jeunes et aussi au à
l'enseignement de faire en sorte de
promouvoir les métier au sein très très
jeune comme le disait monsieur
Christophe EV est-ce que quand vous vous
vous êtes confronté à des très jeunes
salariés qui arrivent sur le marché de
l'emploi vous sentez justement ce ce
fossé entre le monde universitaire et le
monde de l'entreprise on remarque
quelque chose on on sent effectivement
qu'il y a
une une déconnexion entre les les deux
mondes parce que entre les deux c'est
relativement hermétique euh donc à
travers convergence civline on a mis en
place en fait un dispositif qui nous
rapproche de l'université qui permet
sous la tutelle de de professeur de
l'université de détacher auprès de de
convergence civline et des différentes
entreprises qui sont adhérentes euh bah
des étudiants qui vont traiter un
certain nombre de sujets dans leur dans
leur spectre de formation et qui vont
être donc en proximité avec des
créateurs d'entreprise avec des
entreprises qui vont bien évidemment
continuer à être formé à travers
l'université mais qui en même temps vont
être en immersion direct avec des
entrepreneurs et des entreprises qui ont
des problématiques de tous les jours
donc ce qui leur permet en fait
d'acquérir une certaine sensibilité et
de voir comment ce qu'ils ont acquis à
travers leur formation ils peuvent le
mettre en pratique sur le terrain comme
c'est sous forme de stage effectivement
bah ça permet de créer un dispositif un
lien affectif puisque tous les adhérents
de convergence sont des chefs
d'entreprise mais sont aussi des pères
et des des mères de famille donc ils ont
forcément une adhésion forte pour
effectivement favoriser l'insertion donc
par rapport à la problématique de l'âge
moi j'ai eu l'occasion l'année dernière
de prendre pendant un mois euh donc ISU
3e
une jeune une jeune fille qui a balayé
pendant un mois c'est relativement court
mais qui a eu l'occasion au sein du
cabinet de balayer l'ensemble des poste
de la partie je définis le poste à
recruter je regarde comment je peux
trouver la bonne personne av just
partiper à l'entretien de façon à ce que
sur un mois elle a pu concentrer en fait
l'ensemble du process et effectivement
le bilan était très positif parce que
elle s'est rendu compte que tout ce
qu'elle avait appris à l'école ben ça
lui servait le fait de rédiger un
courrier de faire des compte-rendus
de faire des
calculs de
distance de prendre des rendez-vous donc
ça a été très bénéfique il y a aussi je
pense c'est beaucoup plus j'allais dire
beaucoup plus vaste que ça je crois
qu'il faut il faut pas hésiter à tout
faire il faut sensibiliser les jeunes au
fonctionnement de l'entreprise en leur
expliquant j'allais dire presque les
yeux dans les yeux ce que sera leur
métier et leur quotidien dans ce métier
il faut aussi on montré l'importance du
savoir-être par rapport à au
savoir-faire le le le comportement ce
que vous étiez en train d'expliquer et
enfin il faut essayer de changer l'image
de l'apprentissage et de
l'alternance chez les élèves chez les
parents chez les professeurs parce que
c'est vraiment une voix qui permet de
préparer progressivement l'intégration à
l'entreprise et c'est pour ça que les
apprentis et les alternants ont un très
fort
vous CZ tout à l'heure c'est parce que
ils sont directement opérationnels
directement opérationnel al dans la J on
a tout ces objectifs hein je va juste
parler d'un seul nous arrivons bientôt à
la fin de l'émission malheureusement je
suis obligé de de vous couper mais nous
y reviendrons très certainement une
prochaine fois avec toutes ces
initiatives qui sont vraiment très
intéressantes et profitables justement
aux élèves dès la 3è je vous remercie en
tout cas d'être venu sur notre plateau
et d'avoir participé à ces débats qui
étaient très intéressant je vous
souhaite c'est c'est la fin maintenant
votre émission je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée je vous donne rendez-vous
la semaine prochaine pour un prof un
prochain numéro de filcho au
revoir